there are fewer there are few softer
interviewers than Fox businesses Maria
Bartiromo Donald Trump was interviewed
by Maria Bartiromo
on Sunday and he blew it he couldn't
answer even the softest of softball
questions no follow-ups from Maria
Bartiromo no real thinking required and
Trump still pathetically face-planted
and I'm doing this ordinarily I might
show you video clips or play audio clips
of the interview not gonna do that today
I'm going to do quotes on screen and
read them to you because I want to look
really closely at what it is that Donald
Trump says because sometimes the way
Trump talks can make it seem as though
he's not a hundred percent clueless
maybe 90% clueless but looking at the
words that Donald Trump uses here will
show us without any doubt that the guy
knows nothing about anything so first of
all before we put some quotes up on the
screen during this interview Donald
Trump said that the Federal Reserve is
important psychotically I assume he
meant psychologically although who
really knows he was asked whether he
plans to tie an infrastructure plan to
his tax plan and Trump said quote I was
thinking about trying it but I was
thinking about tying it but there's too
many honestly too many too many what and
he kept referring to chief of staff John
Kelly as elegant which was odd to say
the least
okay so there's a report from Trump's
own economic advisors who say that if
you lower the corporate tax rate to 20%
you will increase the average
household's wages by $4,000 now do we
believe that I don't know it's from
Trump's own economic team but that's
what they said you set up a 20%
corporate tax rate household wages will
increase $4,000 here is a quote from
Donald Trump about this from this
interview quote and I think that there's
tremendous appetite there's tremendous
spirit for it not only by the people
we're dealing with in Congress but for
the people out there that want to see
something 5,000 dollars almost it can be
5
thousand dollars average per individual
then he corrects himself and says per
group and so I'm really looking forward
to it let's see what happens he says
almost five thousand dollars now his own
advisers say it's four thousand dollars
is four thousand dollars almost five
thousand dollars I don't really think so
and then Donald Trump first says that it
would be four individuals but then he
realizes he's sort of saying something
wrong so he calls them groups but of
course groups is not an economic term
households would be the economic term
does he understand anything does Donald
Trump have any understanding of
economics whatsoever this was supposedly
the biggest priority for Donald Trump
his tax cuts right give families more
money and he missed States how much
money they would supposedly get and he
refers to households as groups not off
to a great start
Maria Bartiromo then asks Trump about
this new bipartisan health care
legislation that is out there by
Senators patty Murray a Democrat and
Lamar Alexander a Republican Trump's
response unintelligible he says well
I've I have looked at it very very
strongly and pretty much we can do
almost what they're getting I I think
he's a tremendous person I don't know
senator Murray I hear very very good
things I know that Lamar Alexander is a
fine man and he is really in there to do
good for the people we can do pretty
much but pretty much what we have to do
without you know the secretary has
tremendous leeway in the under the Obama
plans one of the things that they did
because they were so messed up they had
no choice but to give the secretary
leeway because they knew he'd have to be
he or she would have to be changing all
the time to paragraphs and Trump said
nothing so far and we can pretty much do
whatever we have to do just the way it
is so this was going to be temporary
prior to repeal and replace we're going
to repeal and replace Obama care he
looked at it strongly the people
involved are good people he knows
nothing about the bill but he's heard
that the people who wrote it are good
people okay and then almost every single
number that Donald Trump stayed
are implied during this interview was
wrong here's just a list of a few of
Donald Trump's misstatements number one
Donald Trump has stated during this
interview that job creation has been
fantastic the reality is job creation
this year has been slower than in 2015
and 2016 on GDP Donald Trump said if we
pick up one point on GDP that's two
point five trillion dollars if you think
of that's not true one point in GDP is a
hundred and eighty five billion dollars
but you know what's a couple trillion
between friends
number three Donald Trump claimed that
three point two percent GDP growth has
not been there in a long time that it
has been a long time since we had that
level of GDP growth of course that's not
true because in the first quarter of
2015 and the second and third quarters
of 2014 and the third and fourth
quarters of 2013 we had GDP growth at or
above three point two percent Donald
Trump stated that the Mexican trade
deficit was almost seventy billion
dollars a year it's actually 55 billion
he / states that by 30 percent and
Donald Trump has also claimed more
progress against Isis in the last nine
months than in the last eight years of
course the reality is that Isis is only
four to five years old why Trump is
talking about the previous eight years
we don't know now this would be
hilarious
if it weren't insanely scary right this
is an interview with absolutely no rigor
or critical thinking required for Trump
he gets away with everything everything
he tries he gets away with Maria
Bartiromo
it's almost like she's not there and the
real problem is that the audience
particularly on Fox Business is so
lacking in critical thinking skills that
they don't realize Donald Trump is not
answering a single question and that the
things Donald Trump is saying or just
flat-out wrong in other countries if you
showed them an interview with a
prominent leader president prime
minister whoever of this of this kind
they would realize immediately this man
is a bonehead but here in the United
States we have this low information
contingent that sees this and says wow
Trump looked strong he looked powerful
he came off as confident we are screwed
folks we are screwed and again
been talking about this for months and I
want to restate it people are going to
see this interview and think Trump did
great great it's not worth talking to
those people if you're trying to change
election results work on get out the
boat because you will never convince
them am I wrong
can you convince these people send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program is made
possible in part by Blue Sky binaries
blockchain Academy blockchain the
technology on which Bitcoin and crypto
currencies can be based many people not
aware of both the power and the risks
that are carried by blockchain
technology I've only started to get into
this a little bit buying a little bit of
Bitcoin here and their dollar cost
averaging but a lot of people myself
included believe that blockchain
technology is just too complicated to
understand but the truth is it doesn't
have to be that way the blue sky binary
blockchain Academy from leading
financial education firm blue sky binary
explains how blockchain works and it can
work in addition to existing knowledge
that you have about blockchain it's for
both beginners and active cryptocurrency
users alike with the course students are
taken through a series of topics which
ultimately will deliver a very solid
understanding of how blockchain works
and help students realize the potential
future uses of blockchain technology
we've talked about this in the
pharmaceutical world we've talked about
this in the IT security world many many
possibilities for blockchain and the
course includes video on-demand online
tests access to a community of traders
and blockchain enthusiasts and at blue
sky binary.com / David you can register
to get a free three-day trial which
includes access to the first module of
the course for you to evaluate the
overall quality and decide if you want
to stick with it get a free three-day
trial at blue sky binary.com / David